so today is the big day
have you thought about what you want oh
well I don't think our building takes
pass on the building okay first piece
for the birthday girl and say some for
daddy just put it in the freezer next to
last year's light hi I'm Brad Excel that
business the fire branch our will be the
tallest building in North America but
failed at what mattered most
yes I know I'm late
you've gotta be here and you have to
bring an exceptional gift now a
mysterious man come in here I'm Tom
brand I own fire brand yes I use the
newspaper in the poopy boxes and I see a
face on top he's about to change
everything
can I just pick out a cat and I'll be on
my way he likes to it yeah keep the
change
okay yes I'm sorry let's do this
so hey doorman wait a minute I'm a cat
how do I get out of this you haven't
been there for your family daddy gonna
come home
I seen it finish this work you have one
week to reconnect with them but you're
gonna be stuck inside that cat for the
rest of your life
but I hate cats what makes this so
perfect seriously who needs a litter box
it's not enough say about someone got
this showing we're the best gift I ever
got just drown me sometimes I feel like
my dad's looking out for me for the cat
I should have been a better day
they make him our eyes for cats I mean
cats cans
miles to go no no
you nailed it
show them I'm human Zola is counseling
visit us read our house could be the job
yes Neha